so let me use the mic to introduce Alex
Townsend who taught here at MIT taught
linear algebra 1806 very successfully
and now he's at Cornell on the faculty
still teaching very successfully and
he's he was invited here yesterday for a
big event over in engineering and and he
agreed to give a talk about a section of
the book section 4.33 which if you look
at it you'll see is all about his work
and now you get to hear from the creator
himself okay okay thanks thank you thank
you for inviting me here I hope you're
enjoying the course today I want to tell
you a little about why there are so many
matrices that are low ranked in the
world
so as computational mathematicians Gail
and myself we come across low rank
matrices all the time and we started
wondering as a community why why is what
is it about the matrices that the
problems that we're looking at what
makes low rank matrices appear and today
I want to kind of give you that story or
at least an overview of that story so
further for this class X is going to be
n by n real matrix so nice and square
and you already know or very comfortable
with the singular values of a matrix so
the singular values of a matrix as you
know are a sequence of numbers that are
monotonically non-increasing that tell
us all kinds of things about the matrix
X for example the number of nonzero
singular values tell us the rank of the
matrix X and they also you probably know
tell us how well a matrix X can be
approximated by a low rank matrix so let
me just write two facts down that you
already are familiar with so here's a
fact that if I look at the number of
nonzero singular values in X so I'm
imagining there's going to be K nonzero
singular values then we can say a few
things about X for example X the rank of
X as we know is K the number of nonzero
singular values but we also know from
the SVD that we can decompose X into a
sum of rank one matrices in fact a sum
of K of them so because X is rank K we
can write down a low rank representation
for X and it involves K terms like this
each one of these vectors here is a
column vector so if I draw this
pictorially this guy looks like this
right we have K of them so because X is
rank okay we can write X as a sum of K
rank one matrices and we also have
initial fact that we already know that
the dimension of the column space of X
is equal to K and the same with the row
space
so the Col space of X equals the row
space of X the dimension and that they
all equal K okay so there are three
facts we can determine from looking at
this sequence of singular values of a
matrix X of course the singular value
sequence is unique
X defines that singular about this its
own singular values okay what we're
interested in here is what makes X what
are the properties of X that make sure
that the singular values have a lot of
zeros in that sequence can we try to
understand what kind of X makes that
happen and we really like matrices that
have a lot of zeros here for the
following read reason if X is we say X
is low rank if the following holds right
because we if we wanted to send X to our
friend we're imagining X is a picture
where each entry is a pixel of that
image if that matrix that image was low
rank we could send the picture to our
friend in two ways we could send one
every single entry of X and for us to do
that we would have to send N squared
pieces of information because we'd have
to send every entry but if X is
sufficiently low rank we could also send
them our friend the vectors u u 1 V 1 u
K up to VK
and how many how much pieces of data
would we have to send our friend to get
X to them if we sent in the low rank
form well here there's to this to n here
too and here numbers this K of them so
we'd have to send to K n numbers and we
strictly say a matrix is low rank if
it's more efficient to send X to our
friend in low rank form than in full
rank form okay so this of course by a
little calculation just shows us that
provided the rank is less than half the
size of the matrix we are calling the
matrix
ranked now often in practice we demand
more we demand that K is much smaller
than this number so that it's far more
efficient to send our friend the matrix
X in low rank form than in foreign form
okay so the Kuo creel use of the word
low rank is it's kind of this situation
but this is the strict definition of it
okay so what do low rank matrices look
like and to do that I have some pictures
for you I have some flags the world
flags so these are all matrices X these
examples because they're Flags happen to
not be square I hope you can all see
this but what the top row here are all
matrices there are extremely low rank
for example the Austria flag if you want
to send that to your friend that matrix
is of Rank 1 so all you have to do is
send your friend two vectors you have to
tell your friend the column space and
the row space and there's only the
dimensions are one of both for the
English flag you need to send them two
column vectors and two row vectors u 1 V
1 u 2 and V 2 and as we go down this row
they get slowly full and full of rank so
the Japanese flag for example is low
rank but not us not that small the
Scottish flag is essentially full rank
so it's very inefficient to send your
friend the Scottish flag in low rank
form you're better off sending almost
every single entry so what do low rank
matrices look like
well if the matrix is extremely low rank
like rank one then when you look at that
matrix like here like the flag it's a
highly aligned with the the coordinates
with the rows and columns so if it's
rank one the matrix is highly aligned
like the Austria flag and of course as
we adding more and more rank here the
situation gets a bit blurry for example
once we get into the medium rank
situation which is a circle it's very
hard to see that the circle is actually
a fact low rank but what I wanted to do
was try to understand why the Scottish
Frank the Scottish flag or diagonal
patterns are particularly a bad example
for low rank so I'm going to take the
triangular flag to examine that more
carefully so the triangular flag it
looks like I take a square matrix and
our color in the bottom half okay so
this matrix is the matrix of ones in
below the diagonal
and I'm interested in this matrix and in
particular its singular values to try to
understand why diagonal patterns are not
particularly useful for low rank
compression and this this matrix of all
ones has a really nice property that if
I take its inverse it looks a lot like
getting close to gills favorite matrix
so if I take the inverse of this matrix
it has an inverse because it's got ones
on the diagonal then its inverse is the
following matrix which people familiar
with finite difference schemes will
notice the familiarity between that and
the first order finite difference
approximation in particular if I go a
bit further in times two of these
together and do this then this is
essentially Gil's favourite matrix
except one entry happens to be different
ends up being this matrix okay which is
very close to the second order central
finite difference matrix and people have
very well studied that matrix and just
know it's I gain values its singular
values they know everything about that
matrix and you'll remember that if we
know the eigenvalues of a matrix like x
transpose x we know the singular values
of x so this allows us to show by the
fact that we know that that the singular
values of this matrix are not very
amenable to low rank they're all nonzero
and they don't even decay so I'm getting
this phone I rang up Gil and Gil tells
me these numbers
that allows us to work out exactly what
the singular values of this matrix are
from the connection to finite
differences and so we can understand why
this is not good by looking at the
singular values so the first singular
value of x is from this expression is
going to be approximately like 2n over
pi and from this expression again the
last guy
the last angular value of x is going to
be approximately 1/2 so these singular
values are all large they're not getting
close to 0 if I plotted these singular
values on a graph right so here's the
first singular value the second and the
N then what would the graph look like
well plot these numbers are divided by
this guy so that they all are bounded
between 1 and 0 because of the
normalization because I divided by Sigma
1 of X and so we can plot them and they
will look like this kind of thing
okay this number happens to be here
where they they come to be PI over 4 M
okay which is me dividing this number by
this number approximately okay so
triangular patterns are extremely bad
for low rank we need things or we least
intuitively think that we need things
aligned with the rows and columns but
the circle case is happens to also be
low rank and so what happened to the
Japanese flag why is the Japanese flag
convenient for low rank well it's the
fact that it's a circle and there's lots
of symmetry in a circle so if I try to
look at the rank of a circle the
Japanese flag then I can bound this rank
by decomposing the Japanese flag into
two things so this is going to be less
than or equal to the rank of sum of two
matrices and I'll do it so that the
decomposition works out I have the
circle I'm going to cut out a rank one
piece that lives in the middle of this
circle okay and I'm gonna cut out a
square from the interior of that circle
okay and I can figure out of course the
rank is just bounded by the sum of those
two ranks this guy is bounded by rank
one because it's highly aligned with the
grid so this guy is bounded by rank one
this thing yeah plus one and now I have
to try to understand the rank of this
piece now this piece has lots of
symmetry for example we know that the
rank of that matrix is the dimension of
the Coast the column space and the
dimension of the row space so when we
look at this matrix because of symmetry
if I divide this matrix in half along
the columns all the columns on the left
appear on the right so the columns for
example the rank of this matrix is the
same as the rank of that matrix because
I didn't change the column space okay
now I go again and divide along the rows
and now the road dimension of this
matrix is the same as the top half
because as I wipe out those I didn't
change the dimension of the row space
because the rows are the same top bottom
and so this becomes the rank of that
tiny little matrix there and because
it's small it won't have to larger rank
so this is definitely less than if I
divide that up a little guy here it
looks like that plus the other guy there
looks like
that plus one and so of course the rows
the column the row space of this matrix
cannot be very high because this is a
very thin matrix there's lots of zeros
in that matrix only a few ones and so
you can go along and do a bit of trick
to try to figure out what how many rows
are nonzero in this matrix and a bit of
trick tells you well it depends on the
radius of this original circle so if I
make the original radius R of this
Japanese flag then the bound that you
end up getting will be for this matrix R
1 minus square root 2 over 2 for this
guy a bit of trig better make sure
that's an integer and then again here
it's the same but for the column space
so this is me just doing trick ok and
that's a bound on the rank it happens to
be extremely good and if you work out
what that rank is and try to look back
you'll find it's extremely efficient to
send the Japanese flag to your friend in
low rank form because it's not full rank
because these numbers are so small so
this this comes out to be like
approximately 1/2 so much smaller than
what you would expect because remember a
circle is almost the anti version of
aligned with the grid but yeah it's
still low rank ok
now most matrices that we come up with
in computational math are not exactly a
finite rank they are of numerical rank
and so I just defined that so the
numerical rank of a matrix it's very
similar to the rank except we allow
ourselves a little bit of wiggle room
when we define it and so that amount of
wiggle room will be a parameter called
hole called Epsilon okay that's a
tolerance I'm thinking of epsilon as a
tolerance that's the amount of wiggle
room I'm gonna give myself okay and we
say that the numerical rank
I'll put an epsilon there to denote a
numerical rank is K if K is the first
singular value or the last singular
value above epsilon in the following
sense I'm copying the definition above
but with epsilon is instead of zeros if
this singular value is less than epsilon
relatively and the case one was not
below so k plus 1 is the first singular
value below epsilon in this relative
sense so of course the rank of 0x if
that was defined it's the same as the
rank of X so this is just allowing
ourselves some wiggle room but this is
actually what we're interested more in
in practice I don't want to necessarily
send my friend the flag to exact
precision I would actually be happy to
send my friend the flag up to 16 digits
of precision for example they're not
going to tell the difference between
those two flags and if I can get away
with compressing the matrix a lot more
once I have a little bit of wiggle room
that would be a good thing so what so we
know from the ark a kin-yuen that the
singular values tell us how well we can
approximate X by a low rank matrix in
particular we know that the k plus 1
singular value of x tells us how well X
can be approximated by a rank K matrix
okay for example when the rank was
exactly K the Sigma K plus 1 was 0 and
then this came out to be 0 and we found
there X was exactly a rank K matrix here
because we have the wiggle room the
epsilon we get an approximation not an
exact so this is telling us how well we
can approximate X by a rank K matrix
okay that's what the singular values are
telling us and so this allows us to try
our best to compress matrices but use
low-rank approximation rather than doing
things exactly and of course on a
computer when we're using floating-point
arithmetic or on a computer because we
always round numbers to the nearest 16
digit number if epsilon was 16 digits
your computer wouldn't be able to tell
the difference between X or X the rank K
approximation if this number was
satisfied this expression your computer
would think of x and XK as the same
matrix because it would inevitably round
both to epsilon within Epsilon okay so
what kind of matrices are numerically of
lower
of course all low rank matrices are
numerically of low rank because absolute
the wiggle room can only help you but
it's far more than that
there are many full rank matrices
matrices that don't have any singular
values that are 0 but the singular
values decay rapidly to zero that are
full rank matrices with low numerical
rank because of the wiggle room so for
example here is the classic matrix that
fits this regime if I give you this this
is called the Hilbert matrix this is a
matrix that happens to have extremely
low numerical rank but it's actually
full rank which means that I can
approximate h2 by a rank K matrix where
K is quite small very well but why did
you give me some wiggle room but it's
not a low rank matrix in the sense that
if epsilon was 0 here you didn't allow
me the wriggle room all the singular
values of this matrix are positive so
it's of low numerical rank but not of
it's not a low rank matrix the other
classical case the classic example which
motivated a lot of the research in this
area was the random on matrix so here is
the vandermonde matrix an N by n version
of it I think of the excise is real this
is very much
this is the matrix that comes up when
you try to do polynomial interpolation
at real points this is an extremely bad
matrix to deal with because it's
numerically low rank and often you
actually want to solve a linear system
with this matrix and numerical low rank
implies that it's extremely hard to
invert so this is low rank numerical low
rank is not always good for you
okay often we want we want the inverse
which exists but it's difficult because
because he has low okay so people have
been trying to understand why these
matrices are numerically of low rank for
a number of years and the classic reason
why there are so many low rank matrices
is because the the world is smooth as
people say they say the world is smooth
that's why matrices of numerical low
rank and to illustrate that point I will
do an example
this is classically understood
a man called Reid 1983 and that's this
this is what his reason was I have a
picture of John Reid he doesn't he's not
very famous so I like try to make sure
his picture gets around
it's playing the piano that's like one
of the only pictures that could find of
him so what is in this reason why do
people say this well here's an example
that illustrates it if I take a
polynomial in two variables and I for
example this is a polynomial of two
variables and my X matrix comes from
sampling that polynomial are integers
for example this matrix then that matrix
happens to be of low rank mathematically
of low rank with epsilon equals zero why
is that well if I write down X as a as
in terms of matrices you can easily see
it so this is made up of a matrix of all
ones plus a matrix of J's so that's 1 2
up to n 1 2 up to n because the every
entry of that matrix just depends on the
row index and then this guy depends on
both J and K so this is a multiplication
table right so this is n 2 4 up to 2 N n
2n n square ok clearly the matrix of all
ones is a rank one matrix the same with
this guy the column space is just of
dimension 1 and this guy happens that
the last guy also happens to be of rank
1 because I can write this matrix in
Rank 1 form which is a column vector Rho
vector so this matrix X is of rank 3
I guess at most Mike 3 is what about
Shoshone okay now of course this isn't
got to numerical low rank yet so let's
get ourselves there so Reid Reid knew
this and he said to himself okay well if
I can approximate if X is actually
coming from sampling a function and I
approximate that function by polynomial
then I'm going to get myself a low-rank
approximation and get a bound on the
numerical rank so so in general if I
give you a polynomial of two variables
which can be written down its degree M
in both x and y let's say keep these
indexes away from the matrix index I
give you this such polynomial and I go
away and I sample it and make a matrix X
then X by looking at each term
individually like I did there we'll have
low rank mathematically with epsilon
equals zero we have at most M Squared
rank and if M is three or four or ten it
possibly could be low because this X
could be a large matrix okay so what we
did for the Hilbert matrix was said okay
well look at that guy that guy looks
like it's sampling a function it looks
like it's sampling the function 1 over X
plus y minus 1 so he said to himself
well that X if I look at the Hilbert
matrix then that is sampling a function
it happens to not be a polynomial it
happens to be this function but that's
okay because sampling polynomials are
integer integers gives
low rank exactly maybe sampling smooth
functions functions like this can be
well approximated by polynomials and
therefore have low numerical rank and
that's that's what he did in this case
so here's he did fine he tried to find a
P a polynomial approximation to F in
particular he looked at exactly this
kind of approximation so he has some
numbers here so that things get resolved
later he tried to find a P that did this
kind of approximation and then he would
develop a low-rank approximation to X by
sampling P so he would say okay well Y
if I let Y be a sampling of P then from
the fact that F is a good approximation
to P X is a good Y is a good
approximation to X and so this has
finite rank you wrote down that this
must hold and the epsilon comes out here
because I do these factors were chosen
just right the divided by n was chosen
so that the epsilon came out just there
okay so for many years that was kind of
the canonical reason that people would
give that well if the matrix X is
sampled from a smooth function then we
can approximate that function by a
polynomial and get polynomial rank
approximations and therefore the matrix
X will be of low numerical rank there's
an issue with this reasoning
especially for the Hilbert matrix that
it doesn't actually work that well so
for example if I take the 1000 by 1000
Hilbert matrix and I look at its rank
okay well I've already told you this is
full rank you'll get a thousand all the
singular values are positive if I look
at the numerical rank of this 1000 by
1000 Hilbert matrix and I compute it I
compute the SVD and I look at how many
are above epsilon where epsilon is 10 to
the minus 15 so that means I can
approximate the 1,000 by 1,000 Hilbert
matrix by rank 28 matrix and only give
up a digit that will be exact to 15
digits which is a huge amount so this is
what we get from in practice but weeds
argument here shows that the rank of
this matrix the numerical rank is that
most so it doesn't do a very good job on
the Hilbert matrix for bounding the rank
right so Reed comes along takes this
function he tries to find a polynomial
that does this
whereas 10 to the minus 15 he finds that
he needs the number of terms that he
needs in this expression here is around
719 and therefore that's the rank that
he gets the bound on the numerical rank
the trouble is that 719 tells us that
the numerical this is not of low
numerical rank but we know it it so it's
it's unsatisfactory reason so there's
been several people trying to come up
with more appropriate reasons that
Blayne the twenty-eighth here and so one
reason that has I've started to use is
that another slightly different way of
looking at things which is to say the
world is semester now Sylvester what
does that mean what is the word
Sylvester mean in this case it means
that the matrices satisfy a certain type
of equation called the Sylvester
equation and so the reason is really
many of these matrices satisfy a
Sylvester equation and that takes the
form okay for some a B and C so X is
your matrix of interest you want to show
X's of numerical low rank and the task
at hand is to find an a B and C so that
X satisfies that equation okay for
example all the matrices the two
matrices I've had on the board
satisfy a semestre equation a sylvester
matrix equation there is an a a B and a
C for which they do this for example
remember the Hilbert matrix which we
have there I'll write it down again
satisfies has these entries so all we
need to do is to try to figure out an a
and B and then a C so that we can make
it fit a Sylvester equation there's many
different ways of doing this the one
that I like is the following
what if I put a half here and three over
to here all the way down to n minus 1/2
times this matrix and I so this is
timesing the top of this matrix by 1/2
and then 3 over 2 and then 5 over 2
so we're basically timesing that matrix
each entry of this matrix by J minus 1/2
and then I do something on the right if
here which I'm allowed to do because
I've got the B freedom and I choose this
to be the same up to a minus sign then
when you think about this what is it
doing
it's timesing the JK entry this is by j
minus 1/2 that's what this is doing and
what's this doing its timesing the JK
entry by K minus 1/2 so this is in total
timesing the JK entry by J plus K minus
1/2 minus 1/2 which is minus 1 so this
is timesing the JK entry by J plus K
minus 1 so it knocks out the denominator
and what we get from this equation is a
bunch of ones so in this case a and B
are diagonal and C is the matrix of all
ones ok we can also do this for vandeman
so vanaman you'll remember looks like
this and then over here we have this guy
the matrix that appears with polynomial
interpolation ok so if I think about
this I can also come up with an a B and
C and for example here's one that works
I can stick the X's on the diagonal
so this is if you imagine what that
matrix on the left is doing it's
timesing each column by the vector X ok
so the first column of this matrix
becomes X the vector X the second
becomes the vector x squared where
squared is done entry wise and then the
third entry is now X cubed and when we
get to the last is X to the n ok so
that's like multiplied each column by
the vector X so if I want to try to come
up with a matrix so what's left is of
low rank is like of this form what I can
do is shift the columns so I've noticed
that this product here this diagonal
matrix has made the first column X so if
I want to kill off that column I can
take the second column and permute it to
the first column I can take the third
column and permute it to the second the
last column imputed permute it to the
penultimate column here and that will
actually kill off a lot of what I've
created in this matrix right here so let
me write that down this is a circumflex
this does that permutation this does
that permutation I've put a minus 1
there I could have put any number there
it doesn't make any difference but this
is the one that works out really nicely
now this 0 is out lots of things because
of the way I've done the multiplication
by X and the circum shift of the columns
and so the first column is 0 because
this first column is X this first column
is X so I've got X minus X this column
was x squared minus x squared so I got 0
and I just keep going along until that
last column that last column is a
problem because the last column of this
guy is X to the N whereas I don't have X
to the N and V so there's some numbers
here ok
you'll notice that see in both cases
happens to be a low rank matrix in these
cases that happens to be of Rank 1 and
so people were wondering maybe it's
something to do with satisfying these
kind of equations that makes these
matrices that appear in practice
numerically of low rank and after a lot
of work in this area people have come up
with a bound that demonstrates that this
these kind of equations are key to
understanding the numerical low rank so
if X satisfies a semester equation like
this and a is normal
B is normal I don't really want to
concentrate on that those two conditions
it's a little bit academic then people
have found a bound on the singular
values of any matrix that satisfies this
kind of expression and they found this
fuller and bound ok so here the rank of
C is off so that goes there so in our
cases the two examples we have R is 1 so
we can forget about our this nasty guy
here is called Ghazala tariff number
e is a set that contains the eigenvalues
of a and F is the set that contains the
eigenvalues of B okay now it looks like
we have gained absolutely nothing by
this down because I've just told you
singular values are bound by Zola tariff
numbers that doesn't mean anything to
anyone it means a little bit to me but
not that much so the key to this bound
the reason this is useful is that so
many people have worked out what these
zola tariff numbers actually mean okay
so these are two key people that worked
out what this bound means and we have
gained a lot because people have been
studying this number this is like a
number that people cared about from 1870
onwards to the present day and people
have studied this number extremely well
so we've gained something by turning it
into a more abstract problem that people
have thought about previously and now we
can go to the literature on zola tariff
numbers whatever they are and discover
this whole literature of work on this or
a tariff number and the key part I'll
just tell you the key is that the sets E
and F are separated
so for example in the Hilbert matrix the
eigen values of a can be read off the
diagonal what are they they are between
minus 1/2 and n minus 1/2 and the
eigenvalues of b lie in the set minus
1/2 minus n plus 1 and the key reason
why the hilbert matrix is of low
numerical rank is the fact that these
two sets are separated and that makes
this is all a tariff number gets small
extremely quickly with k now you might
wonder why there's a question mark on
pencils name there is unofficial curse
that's been going on for a while both
these men died while working on the
solitaire problem they both died at the
age of 31 one died by being hit by a
train it's unclear whether he does
suicidal or is accidental pencil died at
the age of 31 in the Canadian mountains
by an avalanche
I am currently not yet 31 but going to
be 31 very soon and I'm scared that I
may join this list ok but for the Hubert
matrix what you get from this analysis
based on these two people's work is
abound on the numerical rank and the
rank that you get is let's say a world
record bound for the Hilbert matrix is
34 which is not quite 28 not yet but
it's far more descriptive of 28 than 790
and so this technique of bounding
singular values by using these solar
tariff numbers is starting to gain
popularity because we can finally answer
to ourselves why there are so many low
rank matrices that appear in
computational math and it's all based on
231 year olds that died and so if you
ever wonder when you're doing
computational science when a lower rank
appears and the smoothness argument does
not work for you you might like to think
about Zola tariffs and the curse okay
thank you very much how does it work now
okay I'm happy to take questions if we
have a minute if you have any questions
well then I get a spotlight on I'm 31 in
December so they died at the age of 31
so you know next year is the scary year
for me so I will be not driving anywhere
not leaving my house until I become 32
you